TWL is back… kinda… and not here.
As of today, there’s a brand new channel
by Wendover Productions and its called Half
as Interesting.
The videos are about half as long and probably
about half as good as the ones here.
It’s essentially the continuation of the
old TWL series without the restriction of
only picking topics from that wikipedia list.
There’s no more waiting because the first
video is up now and it’s about what’s
the longest continuous drivable distance on
earth.
Videos will be going up there weekly every
Thursday at 10:30 am eastern.
Wendover Productions will remain just as it
always has, the only difference is that you
can listen to more and more of this voice
over there.
I’d really appreciate it if you go over
there are subscribe to at least give it a
try for a few episodes.
I’ve been putting a lot of work into developing
that channel and hopefully it will end up
being something great.